-How are you? How's the fam?
-Everybody is really good.
Thanks for asking.
-Yeah. You're married to
the very funny Melissa McCarthy.
We've talked about this
on the show.
You have --
You have two kids, right?
-That's right.
We have two girls, yeah.
-Do they realize
that their parents are funny?
[ Light laughter ]
-They do not. They do not.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we try to do bits
for them, Jimmy.
And usually,
it's met with a stone face
and then, eventually, like,
"Please stop."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, really?
-What we decided is because
they don't like our bits and
they don't think we're funny,
is that we go the other way.
So, we say, "Okay, fine.
Would you rather
that we're bankers?"
And so, we have these characters
that we play
that are the bankers.
And the bankers
are very serious,
and it becomes much more like,
"Georgette, I hope school
was interesting today.
[ Laughter ]
"Would you please tell me
the longest portion
of your day?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, we do it long
enough, and they'll be like,
"Okay, do your stupid dancing.
Whatever."
-"Go back to the other --
dumb characters," yeah.
-Let's talk about your new show.
It's called
"God's Favorite Idiot."
God, that made me laugh,
just hearing that title.
Can you set up
what the show is about?
I think it's a great idea.
-Sure.
It's really -- It's just about
this unassuming guy named Clark.
I play Clark.
And he is --
he is a messenger of God.
And he doesn't -- he doesn't
know what's happening to him
or why what's happening to him
is happening to him.
And basically, it's a look --
it's a comedy.
And it's a look at
what would happen if, like,
a doofus was chosen
to save the world.
-I want to ask you about this
'cause I know, in the show,
you're in -- fall in love
with Melissa's character.
We were talking
a little bit backstage,
and you said, "Oh, dude,
the proposal was terrible."
-I really --
I knew she was the one.
I knew I loved her very much
and I wanted to marry her.
So -- But I didn't have
all the things.
And, you know,
I couldn't take her
to a top of a mountain
or anything.
And, also,
she doesn't like mountains,
so that would have been stupid
in the first place.
-Yeah, of course.
So take the mountain off.
-Yeah. No mountains.
So I'm like, okay,
well, her favorite place to get
bagels is from this place.
And her favorite place in town
is our back porch
'cause she had
just remodeled this house,
and the back porch was lovely.
So, I've got the bagels.
And I'm kind of starting
to freak out.
And I'm like, "Hey, would --
Uh, Melissa, would you like
to go to the back porch,
please?"
[ Laughter ]
And she's like,
"Oh, boy, he's getting
a little weird on me."
I'm about to, you know,
drop to a knee,
and bang, bang, bang
on the door.
"Who's that?"
"Oh, it's -- it's --
it's a contractor.
He's here to install
a vintage toilet.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, so you can't ask her then
'cause you're like --
-No. Because there's a guy
messing around with the toilet.
Like, I couldn't be
the toilet proposal, so --
-No. What do you do?
You have the bagels.
-So, I've got the bagels.
And so now
we're just eating bagels.
And -- And it's just weird.
And so now,
I take her to a dog park.
Because I'm like,
"Plan B, a dog park."
And then, I'm like --
I don't want to --
you know,
we can't do this at a dog park.
Finally --
-Do you have a dog?
-Yeah, we do.
At least we have a dog.
-Alright, good.
-Yes.
-Alright.
-No, I think --
-That helps. I didn't know.
I didn't know how weird --
-Just randomly take her
to a dog -- No, no.
-We're taking the plumber
to a dog park.
Alright.
What's happening?
Wow.
-So, finally, it's like --
I'm freaking out.
My blood pressure
is just skyrocketing all day.
And the guy leaves.
Melissa is watching
an autopsy show...
[ Laughter ]
...and playing like
a handheld "Tetris" game
that you would play with --
you know,
I don't know -- 20 years --
-Autopsy show?
-Yes. And I literally -- I'm so
Jacked up and I'm freaked out.
And I just rush at her and go,
"Melissa, will you marry me!"
[ Laughter ]
-And...
-And she did --
Actually,
she technically never said yes.
[ Laughter ]
She was just,
I think, so freaked out.
She gave me a hug, and it seemed
like everything was cool,
and we did get married.
-Ah.
You've been married ever since.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations on that.
-Thank you very much.
That's a beautiful story.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-I love it when you come on.
You guys make a great team.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ben Falcone
and Melissa McCarthy
in "God's Favorite Idiot."
Take a look at this.
-I just was wondering, um, if
you'd like to go out sometime?
But with -- But with me, though?
Um, I -- I ask because I think
you're really nice
and you're, um, you're very --
you're very lovely.
Um, and you're --
you're very bold.
And, um, also,
in a non-harassment way
in the workplace,
I wanted just to say
that I think
you're not ugly...
-Ohh.
-[ Breathes sharply ]
...in an attractiveness way.
Ohh, that's not it.
That is not it.
-You basically
just called me a dude.
And an ugly dude.
-Perhaps we could imagine
that I'm doing this better.
Could we pretend, perhaps,
that I'm a Brad Pitt?
I don't know Brad Pitt.
I should call him Bradley Pitt.
Could we pretend
that I'm Bradley Pitt
doing this how he would do it,
like Bradley Pitt is suddenly
inside of my body?
-Oh. That's -- okay.
-Nope. No.
No, Bradley Pitt --
-It's a different visual.
-[ Clears throat ]
He's not -- yeah.
He's not there.
And that just -- let's wipe
our slate clean of that.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ben Falcone, everybody.
"God's Favorite Idiot" begins
streaming on Netflix June 15th.